[Music]
all right
we're starting and we have the move
david
we have to move we're off rain's looking
very focused he's playing a very solid
strategy
just advancing all of his pawns only one
square um
is he heading towards an opening called
the hippopotamus defense
where you just play super solid and last
as long as possible
and the moves are coming thick and fast
david rain is playing
very very quickly which is excellent
strategy
and we do know cooper goodin jr lasted
16 moves
16 moves is the score to beat yeah
that's the record and it looks like rain
is well on his way he's castled his king
he's developed his pieces he's doing
everything perfectly
he's still got most of his time left as
well and i like his position
what do you think ivanka he looks very
active for white he's doing well i love
it
and he has broken through in the center
and you know me i
love it when someone plays aggressively
but look at
magnus he's taking the risks magnus
taking the risks he's threatening things
magnus at age 10. i've played him before
he's a tricky
tricky customer i don't have much
commentary here
excellent excellent um he's doing well
he just needs to
keep that pace he's been uh using so far
uh oh not looking good
magnus does win a piece but the fight
goes on it's still not over
rain still with more than half his time
left and i think he's already beaten
that record
um will we see a queen trade here
rain taking the queens off the board
he's okay he's going for the attack he's
going for his opponent's rook he has
let magnus capture his own rook but uh
yeah he's still fighting
rook down right now for rayne wilson but
he's played fantastically
um still some chances for sure and what
we do know
is that he has played a bucket load of
moves already i have no idea how he's
doing on time
how i'm doing on time oh
magnus you butthole
you um all right i'm kind of
stuck here yeah he might
feel kind of stuck but he is playing
nice and fast he's still got more than
30 seconds left
i got nothing here i got nothing
he just needs to keep that pace just
move his bishop move his pawns okay he's
going active
uh he's just going to recapture now i
really like where white's knight is
placed he could definitely give a few
quick checks later on to gain a few more
moves at least
20 seconds now though exactly and the
clock is
ticking down and magnus's pieces are
coming forward
oh no no no no
no no no i'm stuck
you shouldn't panic just a few more
quick moves you've got five seconds this
is
terrible three two he doesn't make any
mistakes he's unstoppable
one last move and there it is
all right rain it seems you lasted many
moves if you
click continue we'll see the score
30 moves wow wow wow double with the
previous record
congratulations by far a new record how
do you feel about it
oh yeah i'm just not used to two minute
games but boy he's sure good at age 10
was he that good at age 10 because he
doesn't make any
i mean there was a couple times i was
like oh i kind of had a better move
and i think i there was a i could have
brought my knight down
i could have forked sooner there's a
couple things i did wrong
a couple little blunders there but um
i was hoping that ten-year-old magnus
would make some mistakes
it wasn't to be